hallo ich mir geht es gut danke der
nachfrage hat gefragt dreimal dürft ihr
raten wo ich hinfahre richtig zum
bahnhof und dreimal dürft ihr raten wenn
ich sie abhole auch wieder richtig
sander vom bauhof ab weil sie heute in
köln ist das liegt relativ nah und sie
ist in köln weil wir nehmen aber gut
sein da kommt auf jeden fall nach köln
neue folgen podcast aufnehmen und ich
will jetzt erst mal kurz stadt doch
einige passe gar nicht so groß und 100
jahren brot geschmiert unser zuständiger
wir haben wir mitgebracht
ich hatte keinen druck
mit dem aufbau sozialer viertel
muss man leute einfach stumpf sowie
offenfahren fotos wetter oder der
mitmenschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend
es ist so peinlich offenbar in unserer
geschäfts menschen rum weil hier ist
irgendwie banken viertel davon haben wir
hier habt ihr das jugend feuchten kurz
alltag egal als unser neuer fußabtreter
hier
wir haben nämlich mal aufnahme ist immer
so ein bisschen umgeräumt
also sieht jetzt ein bisschen china aus
einem teppich raus hier das hat meine
meinung
wir wollen den sport die hier so eine
rutsche
[Musik]
es ist einfach ein keller bringen
wir nehmen jetzt erstmal podcast auf
eine neue folge dick und doof mit luca
dann kam chris also ein kollege von mir
jetzt auf jeden fall bahn zurück wieder
nach hause nach bielefeld und ich hole
zu komplett deswegen werde ich einfach
nicht mehr sehen und immer mit der ruhe
okay finde so ein mensch den muss man
immer ab und schafft es nicht dass er
allein heim kommt ich sah mehr
abgecheckt wieso sitzt jetzt sind hier
dann noch ein mädchen jugend
sie sind zum ersten mal mit zum skoda
hierdurch köln als zu langsam aus wie
ich liebe meine damen und herren wir
gehen jetzt doch raus eine bar oder
irgendwo anders hin aber an der stelle
würde ich auf jeden fall den heutigen
blog erst mal beenden
ist euch gefallen hat das gerne daumen
hoch da das christ was machst du ich
wollte eigentlich aftershave benutzen
aber nachzuschieben
und du hast einen barhocker fragen in
einer von euch muss sagen im blog es
kommt die leute noch gar nicht
mitbekommen
heute eigentlich mit dem zug nach hause
fahren aber hierzu kann sich technische
probleme dann wieder anderthalb stunden
stecken geblieben ist jetzt wieder
zurück nach köln gefahren und jetzt also
keine ahnung
[Musik]